right now there there's a helicopter
outside telling me to stay inside and
keep my doors locked I've never been
this scared before never if only two
guns could save us if you hear that
helicopter roaming around I warn you two
guns starring denzel washington and mark
wahlberg if you saw the trailer for this
movie you are [ __ ] because guess what
people it's completely ruined in the
whole trailer they take like the last 40
minutes of this film with all the
surprises the twists the turns all that
fun stuff and they basically just made
it all into a trailer to make us think
it's all gonna happen early on in the
film there's some good stuff Mark
Wahlberg he said his Irish Catholic but
his last name is Wahlberg so I thought
it was Jewish for many years he looks
like he could be Jewish I mean one sexy
Jew he's the best thing in this movie
he's really funny yeah he's like the
outrageous characters like Martin Riggs
from Lethal Weapon the best scenes are
when him and Denzel Washington are on
the screen together they're really funny
you know it's great watching another
buddy cop movie or one of them's like
black and the other ones not black and
yet the clashes of that it's it's funny
I like I like black people and being in
these comedies good for them through a
lot of hard stuff but we got a black
president now things are looking up for
black people way to go sister Denzel
Washington he rocks it again guys got
the best walk in the wars on whose was
it goes walking on cloud denso and I
could hang out one day he might be the
oldest guy whose dick I would probably
suck and you they have some really cool
music cool music that is cooler than
this movie it's it's really
disappointing to see that this music was
in this film because its music should
have been in another movie this is
excellent cinematography too it's uh
it's framed well that's the most my
commentaries gonna be on the
cinematography and yes some of the
action is cool some of the action
there's really not that much action it's
it's a that's actually kind of a letdown
damn you people but I don't say this one
was just filled with flaws it has like
this really weird tone it's one of the
weirdest tones I've seen in a long time
weird would be the word to describe the
tone
if I have not made that clear yet it
just didn't know what it wanted to be
some of the work style I've heard in a
long time that looks like the best
dialogue was probably improvised like
Denzel and Mark Wahlberg gosh I got I
got to find a cool black friend I really
want one you know me that'd be cool I
was like having black friends makes you
look cooler I guess the theme today's
review is black people are awesome and
James Martin he's in this movie and I
was excited cuz I love James Martin not
anymore though he just done he's like a
villain in this film and he plays like a
frat boy type of bully for a villain
she's like a whiny little boy who just
wants money and why it's just he's
really he's really bad in this movie
he's really bad really bad it's no one
chance and Paula Patton who was ok
mission impossible ghost protocol and
now she's in this and I swear she was
acting like she was in Fast and Furious
7 but you do get your nipples and her
nipples delicious-looking there's one
shot where it's just like the the next
scene it cuts to and it's just like
pretty much heard her tits and I was
like yes finally we are getting
somewhere with this movie best part of
the movie that's the first reason to see
this movie like all the actors thought
they were all in a different movie each
and the only ones who seem like they're
on the same page or mark wahlberg and
Denzel Washington but everyone else
thought they're a different genre Bill
Paxton Bill Paxton um what the [ __ ] he
was doing this guy was like chewing up
the scenery doesn't work for this movie
just over all the writing and directing
of this was so bad but here's what I
gotta say I like the two main characters
so if they did make a sequel and they
got different writers and directors and
you know a real fast the writing the
right every 10 minutes it feels like
they replaced the writer with another
one this one is so inconsistent some of
the worst writing a long time let me get
straight to the point here oh no I God
see two guns got it wrong
alright guys they shake it out like show
dedicated a black people today why don't
you go ahead school that card box below
and tell me who's your favorite African
American actor and if you want to go
ahead and follow me on Twitter and yes
I'm looking for that special black guy
and if you want to see more in-depth
review of two guns go ahead check out my
show called reasons to see or I have my
white friend on the show with me his
name is Jerry he's Caucasian he is not
black we are looking for a black guy
that one would ever give us a bigger
marketing appeal to the demographic you
know a lot of movies always have one
black person at least and we need at
least one black person last mile at
least if you want to get updated every
time one of my reviews is out go ahead
and click on this button by my penis to
subscribe that's right my penis and my
balls my hairy balls which i like to
call Mark Wahlberg and Denzel Washington
you